today on the matt walsh show why are our
cities being consumed by chaos what's
really driving this that's the
million-dollar question
it isn't a fight for racial justice or
anything close to that these are spoiled
brats who've never contributed anything
of value to society
lashing out against normal hard-working
americans
that's my diagnosis we'll talk more
about it also five headlines including
crazed mobs swarming rand paul and other
republicans as they
leave the um republican convention in dc
last night and we'll discuss
the most powerful moment of the entire
convention and what we can learn from it
all of that coming up
uh much more as well it's a packed show
as always one thing about living in in
the dying days of a civilization is
there's always a lot of news
that's the one positive so let's start
let's start here last night as the rnc
convention concluded writers
protesters again descended on dc and
they comported themselves about how you
might
expect them to here's a here's a quick
taste of the action
[Music]
[Music]
yes yes that was a guy flipping off
running up to and flipping off a small
elderly woman
as she tried to cross the street some of
us were raised to
help old ladies cross the street left as
protesters were raised to flip them bird
and scream in their faces as they cross
the street just a different approach
i suppose who am i to judge of course in
reality
these people weren't raised at all
that's the problem certainly not by
fathers or any other
steady male role model these are spoiled
rotten brats
more than anything else that's what they
are now similar scenes unfolded in dc
overnight including a gang of writers
swarming rand paul
as he left the venue
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
so you notice how there how the the
senator stops in the middle of the
mayhem
to make sure that the police officer is
okay that's because senator paul
whatever you think of his policies and
politics is an
honorable and decent man this provides a
stark contrast with the crowd
surrounding him where there is no honor
or decency to be found anywhere at all
so the question again is raised the
enduring question
what the hell is going on why is this
happening why are these lunatics acting
like this
all the time everywhere and that
question
is one that um then has there are many
answers to it and one that
anthropologists and historians of the
future will be studying and
debating as they sift through the ashes
of our civilization trying to figure out
what destroyed it
what i'd like to do now is suggest one
answer or at least part of an answer at
least
and um i still think that the most
revealing thing we've seen
of all the video of all the footage of
these people destroying and burning and
assaulting and killing
the thing that best captured it all was
the blm activist
in chicago justifying the looting by
calling it reparations
but there was something else she said
that got even closer to the heart of the
issue i think i played this clip
probably three times
on the show already i'm gonna play it
again i'm gonna keep playing it because
i think it's that important let's let's
play one more time here
i don't care if somebody decides to loot
a gucci
or a macy's or a nike because that makes
sure that that person eats
that makes sure that that person has
clothes that makes sure that that person
can make some kind of money because this
city obviously doesn't care about them
not only that that's reparations that is
reparations anything they want to take
take it because these businesses have
insurance
they're gonna get their money back my
people aren't getting anything
these businesses have insurance she
assures us we're entitled to take what
we want
these businesses will be fine now let's
check in with a business owner an actual
business owner to see how they feel
about it this is from the writers the
riots in kenosha uh
first you'll see an older older one
woman surveying the wreckage after the
business that she ran with her husband
for decades was looted and burned and
then you see her son
talking about how devastating this is to
his family watch
look what happened it's still burning
it's not justifiable we have insurance
yeah
but the insurance isn't there so
somebody can destroy
and your things and say oh well there's
insurance
um you you pay for that you know we pay
for insurance
that causes insurance rates to go up
it's basically
that they just stole from us whoever did
this stole from us
and that raises the cost of everything
cost of living goes up because of that
cost of insurance goes up when
insurance claims have to be made i don't
think it's justified for anyone to ruin
anybody else's property it's against the
law they're already put in prison
and order have to be paid made to pay
back what they've destroyed
letting these people get away with this
and holding the cops hands where they
can't do nothing that's wrong
that cops need to be able to do their
job and
and you're not doing this isn't going to
bring
is it going to help your cause in other
words no
you can't just use your insurance and
make everything go back to normal
the devastation is real it is felt and
these are people who are innocent who
did nothing wrong
and were made victims the man you saw
there at his parents
these are just one of the thousands and
thousands and thousands of innocent
victims over the past three months
business owners homeowners everything in
their lives taken from them sometimes
life itself
taken from them um as was the case with
david doran we'll talk about that later
on
but the reason i play that clip of the
blm woman in chicago talking about
insurance
this is a very common theme rioters and
looters across the country have been
using
this line for weeks oh they have
insurance these people have no idea how
insurance works or what it even is
the reason i play it is that it shows
that the the the writers
they simply don't understand why
business owners would be distressed
to see their whole life's work go up in
flames they cannot wrap their puny minds
around it
and uh the rioters
the reason is that the writers have
never done anything of value in their
entire lives
they cannot relate to the feelings of
productive humans
these are societal leeches spoiled brats
who have the luxury to spend their
nights burning and destroying and can
enjoy it
because they've never experienced the
real earned
joy of building something of value or
doing anything of value at all
period we have to understand you know
this is what we're dealing with here
this is an
uprising of the non-contributors against
the contributors
of the unproductive against the
productive
of the brats against the adults the real
adults
of the entitled do-nothings against the
doers
it is a class war but it is not a war
between poor and rich that's another
thing we have to emphasize again and
again and again
the people who are losing everything the
people who have been destroyed by all of
this
these for the most part are not rich
people they're not even upper class or
well-off or whatever term you want to
use
these are mostly blue-collar
working-class average ordinary americans
going back to kenosha for a second
here's a man working man
trying his hardest to explain to the
rioters that they're destroying the
lives of innocent hard-working people
and there's no reason to do it
but he may as well be talking to a wall
because it just doesn't register watch
what you all don't [ __ ] understand is
that people have good lives
[Music]
this is a state-owned building bro bust
my [ __ ]
go they just can't comprehend
what he's trying to say what burning
down a furniture store won't help
spread racial awareness and talent huh
what are you talking about
these are people utterly disconnected
from reality and it's a great
privilege to be disconnected from
reality most of us cannot afford to be
that is why this is not poor versus rich
many of the rioters are more privileged
than their victims
and we've been setting the stage for
this for a long time
a culture and system of entitlement
which coddles and enables and insulates
and breeds
ultimately a generation of bored
disaffected feckless
disengaged brats morally misshapen from
bad parenting or near total lack of
parenting
and their minds rotted from lives spent
ingesting 10 hours of media a day
why do they riot then is it anger is it
hunger for justice is it a fight for
freedom no
it's obviously none of those there is
zero connection between what we see in
the streets
and racial justice they do it because
it's something to do
and because they have aggression and
have no idea where else to direct it
they've gotten bored with video games
and because they're envious envious of
people who have who live
real productive lives and because they
can
nobody's stopping them nobody's ever
stopped them from doing anything
and so they never learned boundaries or
limitations or how to be decent
civilized humans
what can we do about it now well in the
in the immediate in the short term
overwhelming police response overpower
subdue them
lock many of them in prison for years
punish them severely
but the long-term answers are much more
difficult i mean this after all is the
culmination
of generations of moral malformation
it will take generations to undo it
so a lot of work lies before us but i
would say that
now is a good time good a time as any to
begin doing it
let's go to our five headlines
[Music]
well as we'll talk about here in a
second the rnc has come to a close and
so begins the final phase of the 2020
election presidential hopeful joe biden
head to head against incumbent donald
trump
um tonight we're going to completely
recap the rnc for you on daily wire
backstage at 7 00 pm eastern
4 p.m pacific we're going to review the
highlights of the conference compared
the rnc's performance to dnc from last
week as well as the insane reactions
from the left
as we just saw some of that and all
access members you can join us
afterwards for another all
access live where we'll discuss it all
with you personally in the comments and
the live stream
um only all access members get to join
the all-access live session so
go become an all-access member right now
go to dailywire.com
walsh right now to get 20 off all access
dailywire.com
walls 20 20 off all access okay
so uh final night of the rnc convention
the most powerful speech hands down
out without question my opinion ann
dorne wife of david dorn
retired captain murdered during the
riots i'll have more to say about that
in the next segment for now
um you know you could tell the
convention was overall
a success because of what democrats are
latching on to what they've chosen to
focus on
you know they've been on social media
and on tv trying to fire people up
over the fact that the rnc allegedly
violated the hatch act
by involving the white house in their in
their convention
um yes because while crazed mobs are
burning down our cities
they want us to worry about the hatch
act meanwhile
nobody knows what the hatch act is i got
news for you and nobody cares
if you explain it to them they still
don't care um and i don't think anyone
is going to the polls on election day
super passionate about the hatch act i
don't think anyone's going the hat jack
act must be protected the hatch act um
no i don't i don't see that it just
doesn't it doesn't quite
work for a rally and cry and then uh
also of course
we're told that the crowd at trump's
speech
violated social distancing which again
give me a break
you don't get to worry about that or
point that out
while you cheer on these enormous
writhing collections of screaming
lunatics walking around
the city spraying their disease-ridden
spittle all over everybody
okay you can't it just so that doesn't
stick either it doesn't work
um as for trump's actual speech well it
was 876 minutes long
he i think at one point he actually read
the entire script
of gone with the wind as an attack on
political correctness which i thought
that was an interesting choice
so it was long um the content was you
know it's pretty good i don't think
anyone
remembered it 30 seconds after it was
over nobody remembers anything 30
seconds after it's over
the sun could explode today and by
tomorrow we'll all be bored with the
topic we'll also be dead
mercifully but also bored um so that was
the artsy convention let's move on uh
number two the squads ringo
ayanna presley is is added again i
regret to inform you
uh this is what she tweeted a 17 year
old white supremacist domestic terrorist
drove across state lines armed with an
ar-15
he shot and killed two people who had
assembled to affirm the value dignity
and worth of black lives
fix your damn headlines
okay nothing in that tweet is accurate
let's just be clear about that
it is one falsehood after another
stacked on top of each other
if she had a dime for every falsehood in
that tweet
she would have well at least 20 or 30
cents
which incidentally should be the yearly
salary of members of congress in my
opinion
in any case there is absolutely no
evidence whatsoever at all
anywhere that kyle rittenhouse is a
white supremacist
no evidence of it no reason to claim it
other than you're just
a lying hack um in fact there is
positive evidence
against the assertion that he's a white
supremacist based on the videos of him
earlier in the night where he's talking
about the reason why he's there he never
says anything
about race at all he just says he's
there to protect private property
so this is a lie straight up and i hope
to god that kyle
um what he beats hopefully if he beats
this charge
if he's innocent of the charge and beats
it um that he can then go and
and sue this lying hack into bankruptcy
because this is just
you're you're a member of of congress
and this is a 17 year old and you're out
there with no basis at all
calling him a white supremacist if that
doesn't count as
slander um then i don't know what
possibly could
okay now
um oh and then also of course so what
are the other falsehoods in the tweet
let's not just cover let's not cover
just the one
the people who were shot there is no
evidence
that any of them were assembled to
affirm the dignity of black life
um there's no evidence really that any
of the protesters give the slightest
damn about that
much less the protesters quote unquote
who were chasing kyle rittenhouse
and trying to harm or kill him one of
them did have a gun after all now as
i've been saying all
all week all of the evidence we
currently have
and have seen points to kyle rittenhouse
shooting in self-defense after attending
the protest to defend property from
rioters and insurrectionists
and being attacked by them that's all
the evidence we've seen
if if there's some other piece of
evidence out there
i haven't seen it i don't think anybody
else has at least not anybody in the
public
if ayanna presley has some other piece
of evidence she's withholding she should
produce it
but i don't think she does i think she's
just a liar and a disgrace to the
country a democrat in other words
but nobody has produced any evidence so
far publicly
that he did anything but defend himself
from people who were attacking him
of course that doesn't stop people from
just going around and saying that he's a
murderer anyway
okay number three wisconsin lieutenant
governor
mandela barnes has spoken out about the
jacob lake shooting
and here's what he has to say listen
but as the governor said dci's
investigation is ongoing but we don't
need an investigation to know
that blake's shooting falls in a long
and painful pattern
of violence and this is a pattern of
violence that happens
uh against black lives too often across
this country
and as you all know we saw even more gun
violence unfold on tuesday night
when two protesters were tragically
killed and one other injured
by gunshots someone that wasn't looking
to keep peace an outside agitator
someone who came in
from illinois with a long rifle was able
to just walk the streets freely like
that's something normal that we should
just come to expect let me tell you
that's not
anything normal we shouldn't come to
expect that we shouldn't accept it
because what do you think is going to
happen if you have an agitated man with
a long gun walking down the streets
thinking that he's some sort of
peacekeeper and that kind of behavior
shouldn't be enabled either
and we have to deal with the devastating
results of that
we saw that happen in louisville already
we saw it happen in charlottesville
somebody ran their vehicle into
protesters and heather hire was killed
now kenosha wisconsin
is also home to that sort of tragic
scene
we have to not ever want to see that
happen again we don't need an
investigation he says
we don't need an investigation uh he's
we don't need investigation to know that
blake's shooting falls in a long and
painful pattern of violence and this is
a pattern of violence that happens
against black lives
too often across the country um that's
that's what he says there so we don't
need an investigation
no you don't do you mandela uh you you
really don't
you you don't you don't require that as
a democrat
truly we don't need an investigation
should be the 2020
democrat campaign model it should also
be the epitaph
on the this our civilization's
gravestone
of course in reality yes you really do
need an investigation
and you know we keep saying it over and
over again
i know it's just like it it doesn't even
matter because the people saying this
don't care about the truth but um
connecting this
so there there are two levels of of
again we got two levels of falsehood
one is to just flat out say that this
was a murder by the police officers
when once again all the evidence that we
really have available which would seem
to indicate
that uh the opposite is the case that
jacob blake
was violently resisting arrest had a
weapon
in his possession apparently either in
the car that he was reaching into
or he already was holding it one of
those two um
he was the wanted domestic abuser there
on the scene
uh apparently terrorizing his girlfriend
stole her keys
you know all of that all the information
coming out is lining up in
in the corner of the police officer
vindicating the police officer
uh so there's that but then also
whatever you think about the shooting
there's just
no reason at all to think that this has
anything to do with race
uh of course we we automatically connect
it to that but there's
nothing no one has presented a shred of
evidence for that
yet um the lieutenant governor is is
ready to say
but he doesn't matter he does the
investigation racist
murderer first-degree murder hate crime
federal prison he's ready to say that
right away
okay speaking of hate crimes here's a
real one
number four a story you aren't going to
hear on the national news
and uh haven't heard but the report is
from 9 news the nbc affiliate in aurora
colorado says aurora police arrested a
man suspected of stabbing another man
after yelling black lives matter tuesday
evening near
uh east alameda avenue and south sable
boulevard steve sinclair 30 now faces
potential first degree murder and hate
crime charge
charges documents show um
in arrest affidavit says sinclair uses a
knife to stab 29 year old michael connor
who was transported to the hospital for
injuries and collapsed
lung so it says first degree murder i
assume attempted murder because
i don't think unfortunately his victim
survived it looks like connor a white
male told police at the hospital that
sinclair
a black male shouted black lives matter
prior to stabbing him according to the
report it's unclear from the report
what may have led up to the incident but
police say that witnesses saw sinclair
walk up to conor and said i'm going to
kill you and your dog
one witness said conor tried to run away
and defended himself with a stick
um and then uh officers on the scene
showed up
one officer wrote that sinclair had his
hands up when the officers came and said
i stabbed him i'm a psychopath
accurate assessment it seems um and
now he's arrested and they're looking at
right
attempted first degree murder attempted
first groomer and uh
bias motivated crime causing bodily
injury now goes without saying
we don't even need to say it at this
point but obviously
if this was a black man uh being stabbed
by a white guy
shouting white power or whatever uh this
would be
news everywhere cnn will be covering
it'll be the only thing we talked about
for the next five or six days so
we all we all know that now one
one uh way that i think people are gonna
try to mitigate this
is is by saying well this is just a
crazy guy you know he says
i stabbed him i'm a psychopath right so
this is just a this is just an
insane person and it's got nothing to do
with black lives matter or
hate crime or whatever and the thing is
as i have said many times
in an ideal scenario we wouldn't have
the hate crime designation at all
precisely for this reason
because it's it's okay he stabbed the
guy he's an innocent guy just
he leaps out and stabs him tries to kill
him that's attempted first degree murder
does it really even matter you know uh
in a vacuum um
considered on its own without does it
really even matter if he motivated by
hate or motivated by
he just felt like stabbing someone who
cares either way he tried to stab it
should be the exact same
penalty when you try to get inside
someone's head and heart and figure out
what emotions
led them to this it just seems like an
absurd sort of
uh thing to even attempt in the first
place but
since we have the hate crime we
shouldn't have it but since we do since
we have this category
then it has to you have to try to apply
it equally and obviously this
falls right into the hate crime category
but in any case
uh he's a crazy guy maybe he was
okay well see what do you think's gonna
happen
if you've got crazy people out there
and you're telling them all of these
wild fantastical stories
about systemic racism and how you know
cops and white people are out just
hunting black people gunning them down
in the street it's false it's not true
what do you think is going to happen
when you tell a lie like that to a
violent crazy person
as we've seen there are a lot of people
who are not clinically insane
and we see how they react to it
so this if this was a crazy guy um by no
means is black lives matter
absolved in fact they're they are
implicated even more
for driving um for for helping to
motivate and drive this okay five from
wral in north carolina it says a man was
driving his tesla on autopilot mode
early wednesday when he
nearly missed hitting a nash county
deputy standing outside his cruiser
uh dave devander goalie a doctor was in
was in the tesla watching a movie on his
cell phone
while his car drove itself the tesla
apparently not though because the tesla
collided with the deputy's car first
which then pushed into the state highway
patrol car from the
impact um fortunately it seems like
nobody was
seriously hurt goalie works at halifax
regional medical center was driving back
to raleigh when the accident occurred he
was charged with a
with a move over violation and viewing a
television device
while driving i had no idea that was
against the law
i'll keep that in mind for the future
the tesla's market as having full
self-driving capabilities and is created
using artificial intelligence technology
um but here's here's the part this is
what we get to this
this is the this is the headline tesla's
website says that autopilot still
requires attention
from the driver the website says current
autopilot features
uh require active driver supervision and
do not make the vehicle autonomous so
what the hell is the point of that then
it's autopilot but i still have to sit
there
and watch what's happening literally the
only point of autopilot is so that you
can watch youtube while driving i don't
see any other reason to have it
and if you can't do that then it's
worthless i could invent my own
autopilot i just put a cinder block
on the on the gas pedal and it'll just
go forward by itself i mean i still have
to be there to
to drive it apparently that's oh look at
the technology
why does it seem like all the futuristic
technology this is my point all this
futuristic technology that we have
never seems to live up to the hype you
hear you know
self-driving car and it turns out you
still
you still need to drive it so it's not
self-driving you hear there's a new
robot
and you see a videos oh there's some
honda or whatever unveiled a new robot
and you're really excited about it and
then you
you turn on the video and it's just a
hunk of metal that waddles around and
bangs into walls you hear they're
launching someone into space and you
think oh maybe they're going to pluto no
they're just going to the
to the space station which is five or
six feet in the air
according to science uh nothing ever
lives up to the hype
and of course as i say that while i sit
here at my desk
there is the internet which grants me
access to the accumulated knowledge of
mankind
and can instantly give me any
information i want but
who cares about that can't even shoot
laser beams or anything
um let's do a bonus story i did want to
play this for you because i thought this
was this was important important
political story a man in blackface
attended the dc protest last night
for unclear reasons but um
it uh didn't go well for him
surprisingly watch
[Applause]
strength
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
wow that all i could say is that the man
who assaulted governor northam
must face severe consequences we cannot
attack our elected leaders like that
that was the the northam joke i had to
throw it in there all right let's get to
our daily cancellation
okay i don't have a daily cancellation
today if you'll forgive me i did lie
just there uh the cancellation is
canceled just for today and
and uh i am no doubt canceled for
canceling it i understand that but the
reason is that
i want to carve out some time for some
positive recognition for a change
of someone who really deserves it and um
and there's a larger point i want to
make as well but we'll start with
as mentioned before ann dorne the wife
of captain david dorner was
the retired police captain gunned down
by rioters
the entire speech that she gave at the
rc convention last night is five minutes
well worth your time to watch i would
highly recommend you go to youtube or
twitter or wherever and find the video
and watch the whole thing i can't play
the whole thing here of course but
here's a quick piece of it after i'd
gone to bed
david received a call from lee's alarm
company
the front door of the pawn shop had been
breached
this time he didn't wake me up to tell
me
he probably knew i would have tried to
stop him or insist on going with him
as i slept looters were ransacking the
shop
they shot and killed david in cold blood
and then live streamed his execution and
his last moments on earth
david's grandson was watching the video
on facebook in real time
not realizing he was watching his own
grandfather
dying on the sidewalk
i learned of all this around 4 am when
our doorbell rang
the chief of police was standing outside
i wondered why dave had not answered the
door
it wasn't uncommon for him to be up
watching tv at this time
i called out to him several times there
was no reply
he just wasn't there i let in the chief
and fighting back tears he uttered the
words every officer spouse dreads
i relive that horror in my mind every
single
day so that's powerful gut wrenching
horrific
also inspiring inspiring because of the
courage it took for her to stand there
and tell that story if you can only
imagine
you know having to tell that story about
your spouse and inspiring because
of the courage and decency of her
husband now before anne recounts the
murder itself she explains that her
husband david
you know was the kind of guy who made
friends everywhere he went he befriended
years ago a child whose family had been
murdered and eventually the child named
lee grew up
opened a pawn shop and he asked david to
help
him with security for the pawn shop this
is something that david did just to help
a friend he would get up in the middle
of the night
go check on things whenever the alarm
went off um and really think about that
it seems like a small thing perhaps but
think about doing this being on call as
security
when you're retired even at going out in
the middle of the night
just out of the kindness of your heart
as a gesture of friendship
you really know everything you need to
know about david doran based solely on
that one detail of his life this is a
thoroughly
decent man his death was an outrage a
tragedy an injustice
yes an inju is also an injustice
committed committed first by the piece
of trash he pulled the trigger but also
by the state and local elected officials
who refuse to do their job and maintain
law and order
his blood is on their hands too without
a doubt but here's the startling fact
a great many people in this country
do not really feel outraged by david
dorn's death they don't consider it
an injustice worthy of protests or even
moderate attention
it's not an exaggeration to say that the
only deaths that enrage
some people in this country are the
deaths of violent criminals who resist
arrest
it's difficult to fathom such a
mentality if you're a
a mentally healthy person but that is
the mentality of many people
and there are consequences to that as
humans we become what we aspire to we
emulate
our heroes we follow in the footsteps of
our
leaders we are inspired and motivated by
our martyrs whichever martyrs we choose
to raise up and honor in every culture
has martyrs
so what happens to our society then when
we tear down the statues of our
historical heroes
and we choose to ignore modern day
heroes and martyrs like david dorn
and instead we choose to honor men like
george floyd and jacob
blake floyd was a violent criminal and
drug addict who forced his way into a
woman's home put a gun to her stomach
jacob blake was an accused domestic and
sexual abuser apparently terrorizing his
girlfriend when the cops arrived
these are the men we elevate well one
thing is for sure we could say
absolutely the me too era is officially
over then it's been over for a while now
it's officially over we cannot still be
in the metoo
era while making martyrs out of violent
abusers of women
now it's true that just because someone
was a bad guy that doesn't automatically
make their death or injury at the hands
of police justified
the justification or lack of
justification for that
comes from their behavior and choices in
the moment when police try to arrest
them so what do they do
then that's what matters and whatever
else you think about these cases
there's no doubt that both floyd and
blake made monumentally
horrible choices in those moments but
if you think someone's death was wrong
or unjust
you can make the case for that without
making martyrs and heroes out of them
without acting as though
whatever happened to them is is one of
the great tragedies of american history
without explicitly or implicitly
elevating them over
men like david dorn it's one thing to
say you know i think the police did the
wrong thing in this case it's another
thing to paint a mural of a career
criminal and a violent abuser or go
around claiming
that he was a family man and pillar of
the community
when when you take the ladder out you
turn them into role models
and that matters that really has an
impact
that does something and it isn't good
this is not something that we do in a
vacuum there are there are consequences
here
when you walk around the city and you
see murals of
george floyd again a a
violent criminal not a good man
by any reasonable definition
that is honoring him that his honor is
not speaking out against an
in a supposed injustice or simply
protesting
something that the police did that is
honoring the man
and when we honor men like that what
happens
you get a lot more men like that
and a lot fewer men like david dorn
those are the consequences but um that's
why i would recommend that you watch
that and uh
and you know as much as much as possible
to if we can focus on
the focus on you know
i think we need to elevate positive
examples as much as we can
to counterbalance all of this craziness
so we'll leave it there uh for today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening have a great weekend
godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle we'll tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more
see you there